alexis grigoropoulos tué le 6 décembre
2008 par un policier à athènes
l'étincelle qui a embrasé la jeunesse
grecque le soir de la mort du jeune
alexis ce le chaos a gagné athènes trois
semaines d'émeutes dans la capitale puis
dans plusieurs grandes villes
jamais la grèce n'avait vu ça car c'est
le chaos
il doit tout brûler l'annoncé de
l'arrestation du policier ne calme pas
les esprits la jeunesse exprime un
malaise plus large plus profond en 2008
le chômage des jeunes en grèce et de 25%
le taux le plus élevé d'europe
les jeunes sont complètement désespéré
il on parle beaucoup du pas beaucoup de
perspectives
qu'est-ce qu'on leur offre comme futur
la jeunesse unie contre le gouvernement
de droite contre sa politique
d'austérité en pleine crise économique
sans compter les scandales de corruption
qui l'éclaboussent au note que la baisse
ne sera jamais libre
ils sont tous corrompus et sa voisine
ajoute on n'a pas de gouvernement
les affrontements durent jusqu'à la fin
de l'année avant de s'essouffler
presqu'un an plus tard en octobre 2009
la situation n'a pas bougé la jeunesse
sur diplômés sans travail qualifié
baptisé génération 700 euros du nom du
salaire minimum grecque
je vois les serrer partout personne ne
répond alors je travaille ici et je
gagne un peu moins de 700 euros par mois
avec un gars qui est pas là pendant ce
temps là qu ici on travaille 8 à 11
heures passées à 35 euros
en fait tous les gouvernements ces
dernières années ont tué nos rêves
et depuis la grèce a traversé de longues
années d'austérité
dix ans après les émeutes le chômage des
moins de 25 ans a bondi à 37,9 %
toujours le plus haut taux de l'union
européenne
[Musique]